we have all heard the argument that the
world is warming and the Arctic is
melting it may even be ice-free and
summer in just a couple of years but at
the same time reports indicate that the
number of polar bears in the Arctic
which very heavily depend on the sea ice
in order to hunt is increasing so which
set of facts should we believe the
popular narrative of the world warming
and the ice melting or the narrative
that the number of polar bears suggests
that perhaps the ice is fine thank you
to brilliant for sponsoring this episode
reality isn't based on what we wants to
be true or our feelings we have to go
with what the data says and the
International Union on the conservation
of nature has a special working group
specifically looking at the population
of polar bears who they track and count
with a variety of methods if we look at
their data then sure enough they are
very confident that the population of
polar bears has increased in McLintock
Channel the Arctic is such a large place
that they break down the total Arctic
population into distinct subpopulations
depending on where the bears live so if
we look at the population changes in
these different regions we can see that
oh oh no our best data indicates that
bear populations totaling just 3% of the
total population are currently
increasing but that an additional 16
percent are decreasing the majority 55
percent are approximately stable and the
remainder some 26% maybe we simply don't
know enough about this is partly where
the idea of bear populations increasing
comes from as the Arctic is so remote we
still don't know a great deal about how
many polar bears there are but still
more than we knew a few decades ago one
population estimate from the 1950s that
there's been doing the rounds on the
internet is that there were just a few
thousand polar bears remaining that's
obviously quite a lot less than the
20,000 or so today the problem is that
number is based on one highly
extrapolated report from a few Soviet
nesting sites it just doesn't compare to
the wide-ranging rigorous research
methodologies used today by the IUCN in
the absence of total data coverage
are forced to use proxy measurements now
biologists tell us that polar bears need
sea ice they need it in order to hunt
and so to survive so that would tell us
that if sea ice is collapsing across the
Arctic then it would also cause a
collapse in the polar bear population
and the data very much suggests the fact
that the sea ice in the Arctic is
retreating at a rapid rate so how do we
find ourselves in this situation where
the data clearly shows that polar bear
populations are only increasing in a
tiny percentage of cases and more
frequently decreasing but a large number
of people believe that the global
population of polar bears is booming the
discussion of polar bear numbers is an
example of what Xavier Tower refers to
as a keystone domino the truth is that
presence there is such an overwhelming
amount of evidence to support the
mainstream position that anthropogenic
global warming is real and very serious
the opponents and that view know that
they can't win by tackling the evidence
head-on
instead by fostering doubt on a
particular related topic these groups
aim to create what's called dismissal by
Association because if the public can't
trust scientists to be right or even
sure about something like the population
of polar bears then how can we trust the
rest of their conclusions about global
warming of course as we've already seen
there is no evidence that polar bear
numbers are booming anywhere other than
a couple of localized hotspots partly
informed by data and partly by proxy the
consensus argument still holds bear
populations are decreasing on average
and global warming particular in the
Arctic is still a major threat this
strategy of attacking keystone dominos
is frequently used by blogs that talk
about climate change and other related
social media personalities now there are
a great number of blogs that discuss
climate change without really discussing
the science most of which I won't name
so as to not bring them attention but
what I will bring up as a case study is
polar bear science polar bear science is
an immensely popular resource on the
subject of polar bears and climate
change and has published a large number
of articles which for completely in the
face of the consensus scientific the
that consensus view is published in
peer-reviewed scientific journals but
also popularized in blogs like carbon
briefed and skeptical science according
to research by Harvey at our blogs on
climate change very much fall into
either that previous category of anti
science or the latter category of
supported by science there isn't really
a middle ground
this figure shows how polar bear numbers
and sea ice extent are discussed on
different blogs note how one cluster of
blogs neatly overlaps with the content
of scientific papers while another
cluster is all the way over on the right
a huge gap between the two the x-axis
here is basically the degree of
agreement that a blog has with the
scientific consensus well the y-axis
appears to be the adaptive potential of
polar bears to new climates expressed in
the blog clearly they come in two
flavors one supported by science and one
that goes directly against it blogs like
polar bear science exist not to educate
the reader but to ferment doubt in their
mind on the topic of for example polar
bear population in the Arctic and by
association
make the reader doubt the validity of
conclusions of the scientific consensus
on global warming but why what cat the
justification be for discussing science
in a way that completely contravenes the
established conclusions of the
scientific process this is a
multi-faceted discussion that is far too
complicated for me to do justice in this
brief video so I'm just going to focus
on one topic for a full discussion of
which you should check out the excellent
merchants of doubt my Naomi Oreskes and
Erik Conway but in a word socialism the
blog's of today are the latest iteration
of a strategy that ran through the
entire Cold War period and was used to
fight the legislation around smoking
acid rain the ozone layer and now
climate change in all of those cases
science highlighting the dangers of
these topics was opposed by reports
commissioned and circulated by
right-wing think tanks in many cases the
exact same individuals despite them not
being experts on any of those topics the
reason for this was that should the
science go unchallenged to govern
would introduce legislation to combat
the causes of these problems and
legislation was the start of a slippery
slope to socialism almost the entire
debate around global warming has been
constructed by these think tanks and
institutions to muddy the waters and
obstruct policy response to the problem
trusting instead that the free market
would solve the problem well that worked
this debate has been so intense around
global warming because to quote a
rescues and Conway if you believed in
capitalism you had to attack science
because science had revealed the hazards
that capitalism had brought in its wake
global warming would become the mother
of all environmental issues because it
struck at the very root of economic
activity the use of energy sites like
polar bear science are just the latest
version of the PlayBook that we saw
throughout the Cold War and in many
cases are actually run or financed by
the exact same think tanks and
institutions but in some cases they are
run by new zealots who have been
converted by the anti science argument
why that is the case is again too
complicated a topic for a short video
like this but I will say this you get a
lot more attention for being a
contrarian than being part of the
reality supported majority okay but
going forwards say that you find
yourself on a blog that makes some
extraordinary claim about the state of
the environment how can you tell if that
claim is supported by science or not him
and Harvey suggest looking at three
criteria firstly follow the data on many
science contrarian sites the data trail
goes cold basically immediately meaning
that their statements are basically
hearsay and they may as well just be
making stuff up which they frequently do
a science supported site may not list
its data sources but they are all but
guaranteed to link to a paper that the
discussion is based on and that paper
will contain the data sources secondly
follow the money
who has paid for this website to exist
pro science websites are often funded by
universities or through research grants
anti-science websites are typically
funded by business interests or a shell
corporation like for example the George
C Marshall Institute
now the co2 coalition which indirectly
supports Susan Crockford of polar bear
and disputes basically every aspects of
established climate science ask yourself
what would the funding organization have
to gain by promoting this content and
lastly follow the credibility who is
writing this blog and what are their
credentials peer-reviewed scientific
papers of obviously written by experts
in their field and then reported on by
science journalists anti science
websites such as polar bear science are
run by at best quote scientists who were
described as experts on denier blogs in
fact typically have little in the way of
relevant expertise and their expertise
is often self manufactured to serve
alternative agendas this video is
intended to be a cautionary tale it's
not really about polar bear numbers
incidentally again they're not looking
so great what are you counting new
claims on the internet that seem to fly
in the face of the scientific mainstream
such as an increasing number of polar
bears
then I implore you to take a step back
follow the data follow the money and
follow the credibility and you'll quite
quickly discover which websites are
supported by science and which ones are
clearly serving an alternative agenda
and so can be disregarded in an age
where we all individually curate the
sources of our information it has never
been more important to be scientifically
literate the topic of anthropogenic
global warming has been settled in all
but the most my new details in the
scientific community for kind of decades
at this point but a lack of public
scientific illiteracy has meant that
politically it's been contested far
later than the time of which we could
have actually done something to mitigate
the worst effects of climate change and
that was accomplished pre-internet if
we're going to stand a chance of cutting
our emissions and avoiding the
potentially catastrophic impacts of
unchecked climate change as the science
indicates that we are currently not then
we as a society needs to call out and
stamp out scientific misinformation for
political ends I hope that this video
gave you some pointers on how to best
accomplish that and I'll also include
some links down there in the description
that will point you to further reading
this is important it matters to everyone
even if you don't like the idea of
socialism also in the description is
another way to improve your critical
thinking skills brilliant who have
kindly sponsored this episode brilliant
is an educational website and associated
app that are all about solving problems
in maths and science and improving your
analytical abilities if you're naturally
curious like me want to build your
problem-solving skills or develop
confidence in your analytical abilities
then brilliant allows you to do that
with just a few minutes practice every
day they're always adding new expertly
written courses with interactive
elements and recently added the
fascinating history of maths teaching
you maths as it was developed
chronologically brilliant is a perfect
for students wanting to practice outside
of classes or push their knowledge ahead
of the syllabus but also for
professionals wanting to sharpen their
skills or develop new ones if you're
either of those then go to Belinda org
slash Simon Clark and the first 200
subscribers to do so will get 20% off
and support this channel if you've made
it this far in the video then you're all
but guaranteed to love brilliant you're
clearly interested in how you critically
approach subjects and that is what
brilliant is all about thank you very
much for watching the video I really
hope that it has opened your eyes to how
certain aspects of the scientific
internet work and also gave you some
pointers on how to best verify a given
claim on the Internet if you did enjoy
it please do pop it like and if you
think that this work by do here on
YouTube is important then share this
video with your friends and if you like
you can directly support me on my
patreon thank you again for watching and
I'll see you in the next one